[Music]
in gotcha nose news watch whoa don't
give it back you go okay cool thank God
I know right submitted by pad thai I
love pad thai lemon yes or lime extra
lemon or lime extra a woman has been
arrested after biting another woman's
nose off during a fight oh [ __ ] why
would you want to eat boogers how do you
even get that close she's probably like
I like all wrestling and then like she
felt helpless so she was just like
sometimes you're just like you're just
like this close and [ __ ] I just felt
frustrated and hopeless
you're probably oil wrestling in like
bikinis and stuff like usual and things
happen we gotta watch the video let's
just check it out let make sure it's not
anything that's a video that's rude
right here dude I want to watch it with
you your wife is right here um see how
dude that's so rude
I'm gonna watch it with you so get the
engine starting I'm saying oh I'm not
good enough no your engine started cuz I
know you like lesbian [ __ ] oh yeah Wow
that's her engine getting better he
always does it just yeah it makes me go
wild so lucky to you she's a class Oh
lawn mower
okay so this six weeks in Texas this
lady's name is Jessica she's 21 years
old you go from Texas oh she was great
441 mother Jessica know she got bit back
no she's the one that bit yeah but look
at her cheeks she bit a large portion of
the victims nose who they're referring
to as Tatiana and swallowed it crazy
wouldn't [ __ ] [ __ ] like you never
get in this back home into the ear but
the nose got a lot of blackheads I can
see why someone would do it after that
pistol but listen to the story what's
the story there in target there's only
one bag with fractures I don't take the
last brisket so Tatiana went out to a
bar with her next-door neighbor that's
why I don't go to bars okay old
girlfriends
so it sucks I know I went out to the bar
with her next-door neighbor and then
Jessica was temporarily staying with her
neighbors so she joined them as well
with the park to the park so then once
they returned home from the bar Jessica
demanded more alcohol and cigarettes and
then according to Tatyana when she told
Jessica to leave her property the woman
jumped on her and pulled it to the
ground by the hair oh my god and then
bit off a large piece of her nose and
swallowed it what the she says that she
didn't have time to react or to push her
away right has it made no sense
she was either make no sense she's
jealous of us usually I'm always
flirting with you but this time these
are some meth-head behavior and [ __ ]
cigarettes give me some wait where is
this guy's effective
oh well yeah and then she's saying that
she passed out several times she didn't
realize oh my god I wondered until she
was in the ambulance that and now she's
like I don't have a nose I'm 28 years
old and I don't have a nose anymore
what'd she look like I want to see it I
don't have a photo yeah she probably too
embarrassed I wonder how big of a chop
does Jessica have a record of doing that
like a record of nose biting yeah
because I get that seems like a weird
first time ever she knows it's a flesh
wound you [ __ ] yeah you could get
plastic surgery for that yeah that's
crazy whole knows this she has her nose
like cuz the two holes are still there's
just the top part cuz noses don't grow
back to way that they lay shape right no
so there is a GoFundMe for Tatiana
because showing it easy it looks like
just blood funny
their initial goal was $12,000 right as
of right now it's 19,000 dope so she
passed she can get herself a pair of
titties to stop sure there were bad
heads so the doctors said that she needs
to have reconstructive plastic surgery
and if she doesn't have it within two
weeks she would start to heal and the
city would be more complicated it starts
to heal like the old jaggedy like that
reason this was in the last three days
oh [ __ ] dope she can get a gun stay away
stay away from us you finish it from
drunk meth heads that is wild
every time I see a [ __ ] Tweaker I'm
like get ready to kick him in the
[ __ ] balls you're like zombie
Hey
and then just run like a [ __ ] if
something's gonna happen she's literally
a zombie here knows I'm crazy a lot of
the people are donating I see right now
it's a lot of $25 what's the highest
$7,000 oh and a $500 anonymous Wow
there's there's friends and family that
also donate through the link cuz it's
just easier to collect that way for sure
that just shows how many people are
[ __ ] awesome
yeah I wonder if there's people in there
that just browse [ __ ] go funnies and
Kickstarter's and and they're just
waiting to like give to something
awesome yeah cuz you know what I do I
judge a lot I'm like dude the ideas bomb
but I bet you the team can't do it
I got a GoFundMe message someone
messaged me on Instagram and this chick
just sent me the link and then like six
hours later said anything helps and as I
looked at it it was basically I need
money because I need to pay off some
credit card bills and I want to get out
of my car lease cuz I want to start a
family of my boyfriend I think I got
that same one oh did you yeah and then
the boyfriend sent it to me saying like
hey I'm trying to move out with my
girlfriend yeah physical fun really
everybody this kid message me and he's
like hey I'm a big fan um like all I
need is $3,000 for a laptop so I could
be a youtuber and start my career
yeah that's why yes for three thousand
dollars I'm like I don't have that I'm
not pewdiepie like there's this one girl
that's shared on Facebook like I need
money for a boob job and I'm like what
the [ __ ] and I was like how about you
get a job she goes well I need it by
like in three months I'm like why she
goes oh because it's my 21st birthday
and I want to gift it to myself what
yeah you're getting someone to gift it
to you dumb [ __ ] go far I'm getting
money for vacation I deserve it because
I've been working so hard
one girl post you know there's a one
girl I posted wow I mean 400 ollars to
fix my phone screen and be like why
don't you just get a job she goes you
know import models don't make that much
money we rely on our boyfriends and our
parents
I was like no they don't know yeah I
know many amber Manos who like make
money on their own it's fine what kind
of self-proclaimed import model is she
great that's weird
people make GoFundMe is for the dumbest
[ __ ] ever you know what's even more sad
the people that give money to these
people yeah
what do you why are you they feel bad
all of these but I've just mentioned
they got shamed and they didn't get any
money and they shut it down I try to do
like when I was trying to donate to a
charity a month I do that too resolution
no night see or get connected today
sorry G and not Gio other works yeah I
don't trust none of that [ __ ] yeah she's
been diagram organization that they have
oh and then every time you make an
Amazon purses purge okay
everything into the camera safe to the
camp that's gonna stay went tips done
finished every time you make an Amazon
purchase you're done it's a little small
port it's true a supermarket when you
have all you want to add $2 to like the
pet foundation order like that I'm
waiting anything like that but then if I
don't trust none of that [ __ ] you know
Tyga's [ __ ] college fund [ __ ]
you [ __ ] years of pulse dude I'm
offended while you're doing a parent's
job you're such a that's crazy get a
college fund no the government gave it
to me but I'm not entitled I got one but
I was like no thanks i'mma tell lady to
be an actress
no no because they wouldn't get they
wouldn't give it to me unless I was
going to college I also had a
scholarship that was would allow me to
go to any college in California and I
was like not for me
dang
scholarship for it was for getting
higher test scores on the California
tested your dad have a heart attack ya
know even to like a couple years ago
he's like you know you have to tell 30
to use the scholarship if you wanna yeah
how much was you got that scholarship a
couple thousand dollars your bus ticket
I knew that College was to prepare for a
future for your future career and I was
like what if you gave me the same money
and I used it in on like the best acting
conservatory program the best acting
coach is like I used it to study for my
craft and they were like no you're not
get a degree at the end what if it was a
theater degree people don't use their
degrees anyway but what if it was a
theater degree no cuz theater degrees
aren't they don't really help you get no
no but would your parents be satisfied
with us acting or theorem they would
have but that makes no sense like if you
put money into acting classes in
Hollywood versus going to like you see
whatever and in going getting a theater
degree there it's it's worse actually
their mentality was as long as you have
the degree you can go get a job you're
like safe that's a [ __ ] but the
rules are outdated cuz you're just no
job like 40 years all dated yeah that's
not like a bruise [ __ ]
[Music]